i am here for you
i mean i'm trying so i got you this
right here
in remembrance of you all right oh wow
honey you know honey you just got to get
a job
yes honey i know and provide for the
family and pay bills and all that good
jazz i know exactly what's going on been
doing it for a long time now
long time i forgot your fault in civil
war
uh thank you it was nam okay
[Music]
yeah it's gonna be there forever too
yeah just like i'll be your pumpkin
forever
give me a kiss i don't want no kiss now
you've been dry heaving and stuff now
i'll kiss your hand all right
i'm out of my hair you did yeah
quit ticking your finger in there
are you excited about your birthday
party yeah what kind of dress are you
going to wear
a chocolate dress a chocolate dress
i think it will melt
what kind of things do you want like to
eat it's at your birthday party
um cake i think we should get a big cake
let's go little cake it's gonna be a lot
of fat people here foods
yeah so we're gonna need a big cake
i want gigi to come to my part
for well why
because i'm the best oh here's the best
well i guess if you want gigi here
i will call her